. Ba ba ba ba ba Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zum Das-Podcast-Ufo. Das ist ein neues Intro. Sehen Sie heute Stefan Titz in ihrem erneuten Kampf gegen die deutsche Sprache. Stefan Titz! Herzlich willkommen, Florentin Will. Man weiß nicht genau, wofür die Sätze hin, sind sie eher wie eine Hängebrücke, wo man sich konzentrieren muss, wenn man am Ende des Satzes ankommt. Kommt man überhaupt ans Ende oder nicht? Es ist alles ein bisschen so ein Joyride. Ja, es ist ein bisschen spaßig tatsächlich. Es ist ein Adventure. Jeder Satz ist ein Adventure. Liebe Zuhörer, damit ihr diese Aufregung ein bisschen versteht, Stefan und ich sitzen uns heute mal wieder leibhaftig gegenüber, in der fleischlichen Lust inkarniert sitzen wir. Und die alle Hörer rollen mit den Augen. Ich kann spüren, keiner hat Bock darauf zu reden. Ja, natürlich. Es ist furchtbar, nicht anzugucken. Es kann wieder eine Schicksalsnacht werden heute, aber ich meine, wir können uns berühren, wir können uns fühlen, wir können uns in seelischer Zweisamkeit diesen Abend genießen. Stefan stellt sich irgendeinen Timer komisch. Ja, ich habe eine Stunde eingestellt mal, damit wir mal genau eine Stunde reden. Ich habe so eine Podcast-Seite gefunden, wo auch die Zeiten stehen, die durchschnittliche Zeit, die wir pro Folge benutzt haben. Es war ungefähr eine Stunde, eine Minute oder so. Es war mega gut. Es war einfach mega fast genau. Ja, ich glaube, der Durchschnitt ist immer eine Stunde. Ich glaube, das ist einfach eine Zeit, die der Mensch an sich gewöhnt hat. Ich glaube, letztendlich ist man einfach so an diese Zeitkonformitäten gewohnt. Ich kann mich heute echt nicht einziehen, du hast das William-Mikro wieder in der Hand. Was wir immer, wenn wir hier aufnehmen, hat einer von uns das William-Mikrofon. Aber das ist ein super geiles Mikrofon. Das ist von William Cohn. Man muss ja mal tatsächlich sagen, das ist eines der Original-Roche und Bömermann-Mikrofone. Eines der sieben Mikrofone, die auf dem Roche und Bömermann bestanden. Was ist mit den anderen fünf passiert? Ja, in der Hand. Die sind in irgendeiner Schlucht in den Schicksalsberg geworfen, brennen, da wo sie geschmiedet wurden. Genau, ich bin ein Mikrofonträger gerade, ich habe eines der sieben legendären Mikrofone. Im Moment die magische Macht... Du bist immer mehr zum Arschloch bis zum Ende der Folge, am Ende bist du ein dummes Arschloch. Genau, aber wenn sie irgendwann mal wieder zusammengeführt werden, die sieben Mikrofone, dann entsteht die beste Fernsehsendung aller Zeiten. Wer weiß, ob das vielleicht heute noch stattfindet, wer heute alles noch dabei kommt, man weiß es nicht. Aber tatsächlich sind diese Mikrofone heute, die wir benutzen, so extrem viel wert, dass es sich tatsächlich lohnen würde, wenn wir während der Aufnahme beschliessen, einfach in unser Karbiro zu steigen, nach Mexiko abzureisen und dort den Rest unseres Lebens zu verbringen. Und einen Podcast aufnehmen, haben wir eben schon gesagt. Wir nehmen einfach auf der Reise einen Podcast auf und geben auch immer auch kontinuierlich unsere Koordinaten durch, damit wir gute Geschichten erzählen können.
Wo sind wir gerade und man wird uns vielleicht finden. Aber was hat das Wert dann?
Wann ist das eigentlich so bei iPhones und sonstigen Geräten, dass man, wenn man eine Message schreibt, dass der Ort dann angezeigt wird?
Ich finde, es ist immer ein bisschen arg random irgendwie. Ich kriege von Leuten eine Message irgendwie, ja, hey, wie geht's dir, send from Berlin oder so.
Einfach ganz random.
Bei Facebook dann?
Nicht irgendwie, das ist sehr komisch.
Das ist echt komisch. Gibt es da irgendeinen Logarithmus, dass Facebook merkt, wann der Ort relevant ist? Du kannst es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht mehr so, dass es nicht ich interessant. Ich stelle mir Facebook einfach immer wie so einen Typen vor, der sich mit einem Bier in der Hand dann zurücklädt und dann so, ja mal schauen. Mal gucken, was passiert, der so tausend Monitore vor sich hat und in so einem ganz hohen Ruhm sitzt. Und einfach genießt. Genauso wie diese WhatsApp-Häkchen. Also wie stehst du dazu? Ich habe da viel drüber nachgedacht, ob das der Kommunikation behilflich ist oder nicht. Ich habe da echt viel drüber nachgedacht. Es geht, es geht. Dass man sehen kann, wenn der Gegenüber die Message gelesen hat oder nicht. Ist das positiv eigentlich oder ist das nur Schikane?
Also ich denke immer ans normale Reden.
Und beim normalen Reden ist es ja so, dass du auch merkst, wenn der andere gehört hat, was du gesagt hast.
Aber er kann es ignorieren.
Er kann so tun, als hätte er es nicht gehört.
Er kann sich dadurch einen negativen Vorteil verhalten. Natürlich kann er es nicht.
Natürlich kann er es nicht.
Niemand kann das so glaubhaft, dass man dann wirklich denkt, oh, der hat mich nicht gehört wahrscheinlich.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube doch.
Na, was nicht.
Ich glaube auch nicht. Aber ich meine,
du kennst es ja, machst du das manchmal, wenn du
eine Message kriegst und sie nicht sofort liest,
weil du nicht willst, dass der andere sofort
merkt, dass du sie gelesen hast? Ja, ich versuche dann so
mich selber zu betrügen und hoffe, dass es
all von merkt. Ich gucke drauf, aber nur ganz kurz.
Ich habe es draufgeguckt, dass du den
Zuckersteller wieder weg. Aber ich habe nicht gesehen, wer es ist, von daher kann
ich gar nicht wissen, wer die Antwort hat. Ey, sorry Siri, ich habe nicht
draufgeguckt, wirklich. Bitte, ey. Ein 20-minütiges psychoanalytisches Gespräch mit Siri, von daher kann ich gar nicht wissen, wenn die mal antworten hat. Hey, sorry Siri, ich habe nicht drauf geguckt, wirklich.
Bitte, ey.
Ein 20-minütiges psychoanalytisches Gespräch mit Siri, warum du das jetzt gerade nicht konntest.
Hingucken, ganz schnell wieder weggucken.
Visuell habe ich gerade sehr gute Gags gemacht, aber ich habe leider nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, wenn ihr über Periscope tatsächlich uns zuschauen wollt, dann macht das, schaut auf den Periscope, den wir bei Twitter drei Stunden nach der Aufnahme gepostet haben.
Schaut einfach mal rein, um das leere Studio zu sehen.
Aber ich weiß noch nicht genau, was für diesen Haken zählt. Also zählt schon, wenn du es auf deinem Display gesehen hast? Nein, es gibt drei Stufen. Ah, okay, erklär mich mal auf. Es gibt die erste Stufe, das ist der eine graue Haken. Der heißt, der sagt, du hast dich erfolgreich weggeschickt. Ja, das habe ich auch nicht verstanden, aber was heißt es? Die ist raus aus deinem Handy. Ja, aber das impliziert ja, dass sie im anderen Handy noch nicht angekommen ist. Ja, genau. Vielleicht war die kein Netz haben gerade, weil er auf dem Mount Everest steht oder so. Oder sein Handy aus. Du hast zumindest dein Handy verlassen, das heißt, es ist nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen. Es wird irgendwann mal ankommen, wenn das Handy mal wieder Empfang hat. So, dann gibt es zweite Stufe zwei graue Haken, die der Empfänger hat das bereits empfangen. Aber noch nicht gelesen. Nicht gelesen. Okay, ich bin nicht komplett bescheuert, also ich glaube, aber jetzt komme ich alleine weiter, danke.
Jetzt mit so einer Kindersprache.
Und dann kommen die zwei blauen Häkchen und was machen die kleinen blauen Häkchen.
Ja, ich fände es doch gut, wenn es noch ein blauen Häkchen gibt.
Er hat es gelesen, aber nicht verstanden.
Und zwei blauen Häkchen, er hat es gelesen und nicht verstanden.
Ja, das hat jeder schon gemacht.
Ich weiß, aber ich komme mir tatsächlich gerade extrem alt vor, einfach, weil ich habe das Gefühl,
mein Enkel erklärt mir gerade was. Wir haben auch ein graues Haber, der er entdeckt neulich.
Ja, das hat jeder schon gemacht. Ich weiß, aber ich komme mir tatsächlich gerade extrem alt vor, einfach, weil ich habe das Gefühl, mein Enkel erklärt mir gerade. Wir haben auch ein graues Haber, der entdeckt neulich. Ja, aber das konnte ich nicht rekonstruieren. Ich habe es nicht mehr wiedergefunden, tatsächlich. Ja, ja, du hast es einfach rausgerissen, weinend, hast du einen Abend in der Dusche verbraucht, hast es rausgerissen. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, was ihr da in meinem Kopf gesehen habt, aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur Rückstände der letzten durchzechten Nacht. Hobbys, was hast du eigentlich so für? Nein. Mal ganz kurz, wir haben uns heute was ganz Besonderes vorgenommen, und zwar haben wir GoButler, unsere Lieblings-App, gefragt, es ist keine App, es ist ein SMS-Dienst, wir haben gefragt, was wollen wir als für ein Thema besprechen, haben den besten SMS-Dienst gefragt, was ist euer Vorschlag, das machen wir, ungefragt, ungefiltert, einfach blind übernehmen, was die uns gesagt haben. Und das Thema ist heute Universum. Das heißt, wir haben in beidem Sinn ein Scheißthema und können uns aussuchen, was wir wollen. Also im Prinzip ist es wieder sowas wie Chancen, so eine Folge zum Abschalten eigentlich, oder? Ja, eigentlich, also wir machen heute mal eine Relax-Folge. Max, relax. Ich sag mal, ich will heute den Fokus der Unterhaltung auf den Zuschauer lenken. Dass der Zuschauer sich mal selber überlebt, mach dir deine eigene Unterhaltung. Lass dir selber was einfallen. Du brauchst nicht immer das Podcast-Ufo, um einen schönen Abend zu haben. Du hast einen florierenden, vorstellungskräftigen Geist, du hast einen wunderschönen Körper, geniesst die beiden in Kombination. Mach dir heute mal selber einen wunderschönen Abend. Geh mal raus, mach einen Spaziergang, geh baden, erforsche deine Gefühle, geh mal in dich. Du brauchst nicht immer Stefan Titzel. Lies mal ein Buch vielleicht auch. Ja, lies mal ein Buch. Oder ich habe jetzt entdeckt, ich habe bei Spotify, es gibt ganz, ganz tolle Hörbücher. Da kann man wirklich tolle Hörbücher und Hörspiele, da kann man ein abendfüllendes Programm hat man da. Ja, genau, das heißt, wir werden uns euch heute einfach mal präsentieren, was ihr tun könnt, ausserhalb von das Podcast-Ufo hören. Das ist unsere Aufgabe heute. Okay, was kann man denn so machen? Also wir beide wissen ja anscheinend nicht so viel, das hätten wir ja gar nicht erst gemacht. Ich kann mich auch an die Zeit gar nicht mehr erinnern, wo ich eine Woche lang keine Stunde hatte, wo ich mit jemandem über mein Leben rede. Nee, aber würdest du sagen, du hast dich als Mensch dadurch weiterentwickelt, also diese Zeit mit sich selbst beschäftigen? Ich finde es gut, ich war schon immer ein sehr reflektierter Mensch. Ich habe immer sehr oft über mein Leben nachgedacht,
über mich nachgedacht, warum ich so bin, wie ich bin,
warum ich da so reagiert habe. Ich bin ein sehr nachdenklicher Mensch.
Und ja, das hat sich nicht
großartig geändert. Jetzt habe ich halt
so ein Ventil, wo ich es rauslassen kann.
Aber hast du das Gefühl, du bist durch diese Selbstreflektion
ein glücklicher Mensch geworden oder
ziehe dich das eher runter? Wie gesagt, dank dass du mir
nicht zugehört hast, ich war immer schon sehr
selbstreflektiert. Wie bitte? Ich war immer schon sehr selbstreflektiert, wie wird das? Ich war immer schon sehr selbstreflektiert, aber jetzt habe ich ein Ventil, jetzt kann ich es endlich mal rauslassen, jetzt kann ich mich mal in meinem Leben daran teilhaben lassen. Aber ich meine, hilft dir diese Selbstreflektion oder steht sie dir eher im Weg? Ich habe die Frage nicht verstanden. Bist du durch Selbstreflektion ein glücklicherer Mensch oder nicht? Ja, ja. Warum, wie äussert sich das? Du bist. Du weißt, du weißt mittlerweile, was dir gefällt, was dir nicht gefällt. Ja, aber du weißt auch, was deine Probleme sind. Du hast eine Haltung. Ja, genau, du hast zumindest darüber gesprochen. Ja, aber ist es nicht besser, wenn du eigentlich eher keine Ahnung hast, was deine Probleme sind? Wenn du keine Ahnung hast über Dinge, hilft es oft, die Dinge zu verinnerlichen, sich mit ihnen auseinanderzusetzen und die Dinge zu erklären wiederum. Aber man sagt ja auch, dass Nachhilfelehrer, also wenn du als Schüler da mal Nachhilfe gibst, dir das selber noch mal viel hilft, weil du halt die Themen, wenn du die erklärst, komplett verstanden haben musst. Und wenn du das genauso, wenn du über dein Leben redest, in den Podcasts, weil du eine Stunde lang das Podcast-Ofen nennst und das fünf Bewertungen auf podcast.de hat was weiter dritt haben, dann hast du angefangen über deine... Fünf mal zwei Sterne. Genau. Dann hast du angefangen, über dein Leben zu erklären, dein Leben zu erklären, und dann hast du es doch verstanden. Das ist ganz gut für dich. Ja, aber ist das Verständnis unbedingt immer positiv? Also man sagt ja auch, also wenn wir jetzt mal bei der Akkommodationsebene, man sagt ja. Ich habe auch gelegt, wir haben ja jetzt, also wir sollten, finde ich, nicht Werbung machen für Flatter. Wir sollten nicht Werbung machen dafür, dass man uns das spenden kann. Kein Fall. Also ich würde nicht gerne die URL Flatter, Flatter, F-L-A-T-T-R.de, das Podcast-UFO erwähnen, einfach weil man uns da spenden kann und uns da ein bisschen helfen kann, um vielleicht ein neues Mikrofon zu kaufen. Wo wir gerade am Einleiten gesagt haben, dass es im Mikrofon so viel wert ist, dass wir damit das Land verlassen können und den Rest unseres Lebens davon leben können. Ich glaube, wir sind der Un... Also wir verdienen keine Spenden. Also ich meine, ganz ehrlich, wir verdienen keine Spenden. Ich dachte immer, man kann richtig viel Geld verdienen. Dachte ich immer, man meint so drei Euro. Ich glaube, man kann auch von viel Geld verdienen, wenn man eine große Reichweite und viele Leute, die einen hören, aber haben wir ja nicht. Von daher, und wir brauchen auch keine Geld. Sind wir die Menschen, die man spenden sollte? Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Aber ich meine, man hat ja auch ein bisschen das Bedürfnis, was zurückzugeben. Also so eine Beziehung ist ja immer ein Geben und Nehmen. Und wenn man immer nur nimmt, fühlt man sich irgendwann schlecht. Das ist beim Podcasten genauso wie bei zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen. Und deswegen kann man da anventieren. Aber unsere Hörer geben uns total viel. Unsere Hörer geben uns, klar, Feedback und ganz tolle Bilder und auch diese tolle, diese tolle Tweet, die wir bekommen haben, wo eine Hörerin gesagt hat, dass sie Sex hat, während sie unseren Podcast hat. Ja, das stimmt. Paula Paula, da wollen wir eigentlich tatsächlich mal drauf. Pauline, tatsächlich haben wir, ich finde es immer ganz schön, wenn man Menschen direkt in Schubladen stecken kann und ich glaube, bei uns, beim Podcast-Ufo, in der Hörerschaft passt das ganz gut und zwar werden wir hauptsächlich von Menschen gehört, deren Name mit Paul anfängt. Wir haben eine Paula, wir haben eine Pauline, die uns regelmäßig schreiben und... Und ein Kevin, keine Ahnung, wie der
zuzukommen ist. Und ein Kevin, ja.
Das heißt, wenn ihr Paula oder Pauline heisst,
habt es eine sehr grosse Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass ihr gerade das Podcast-Ufo hört.
Herzlich willkommen an der Stelle. Herzlich willkommen erstmal an der Stelle,
was macht ihr hier? Ihr habt offensichtlich
ein aktives Sexleben, von daher, was
macht ihr, uns beiden
Idioten dabei zuzuhören, wie wir versuchen
zu erklären, warum wir keinen Sex haben? Naja, naaja, also man kommt drauf an, mit wem jetzt? Ich glaube, meinst du, meinst du, meinst du, ist es möglich, das war eine Feedline für eine Punchline, die wir dir aber nicht haben. Meinst du, ist es möglich, mit jemandem Sex zu haben, der dann schlechter ist, als das Podcast-Ufo zu hören? Oder ist Sex generell, egal mit wem, besser als das Podcast? Ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass man sehr gut mit Leuten Sex haben kann, die nicht bei Bewusstsein sind. Das ist so, dass du die Erfahrung nicht gemacht hast. Aber letztens hatten wir so ein krasses Delay. Ich habe die Folge geschnitten und es war wirklich schlimm. Ich habe immer was gesagt, dann kam eine halbe Stunde lang ein Nick und dann kam ein Lacher von einem Witz, den ich davor gemacht habe irgendwann. Das war einfach nur furchtbar anstrengend und auch gar nicht schneidbar. Am Anfang haben wir gesungen und das war wirklich das Beste, was wir gemacht haben, jemals. Wenn wir nicht gesungen hätten, hätte ich niemals das synchronisieren können. Was hast du gemacht nochmal genau? Du hast einen VPN-Aktivität. Ich habe jetzt nämlich Netflix.com tatsächlich entdeckt für mich, also die amerikanische Variante. Was ist da denn mehr drauf? Was haben die denn anderes? Wahnsinnig viel, ganz viele amerikanische Serien, die es in der deutschen Version gar nicht gibt und alles so, von daher ist es tatsächlich sehr gut, aber man muss so einen VPN-Service machen, der eben auch immer so ganz ganz fies reizt, der auch immer so kommt, also VPN bedeutet, dass man über einen Proxy-Server dann... Ja, aber du kannst bei dir ja nicht mehr so viel kaputt machen eigentlich. Ja, nee, aber das ist dann immer so... Du machst es an und dann sagt er, ja, ich erfülle alle deine Träume. Alles wird gut, du kannst alles anschauen, was du willst. Und langsam drosselt er deine Bandbreite. Immer weiter und denkst du, was ist denn los, warum lädt denn nichts? Und irgendwann kommt dann so ein Pop-up, so ganz nebenbei gerade erwähnt. Es gibt auch eine Premium-Version von unserem VP-Ending. Also jetzt nur, falls es da Bedarf gäbe, da hast du dann doppelte Bandbreite und unlimitierend so und dann kommt man rein. Du hast erst mal Bandbreite. Ich zahle auch Instant, habe sofort gezahlt, aber es hat immer noch nicht funktioniert, habe ich da gelöscht. Auf jeden Fall, ich bin immer sehr schnell dabei, Geld auszugeben. Ja, dazu Watch Ever auch, boah, ich habe gegessen zu werden. Du hast Watch Ever dir geholt, hast bezahlt und dann wieder gekündigt, weil du gemerkt hast, dass die Serie, die du da gucken wolltest, endlich gar nicht da ist. Ja, genau, ich wollte eigentlich nur eine Serie haben, Kirby Enthusiasm, und habe gemerkt, dass es die nicht mehr gibt anscheinend. Früher gab es die und habe sofort wieder gekündigt und habe zehn Euro zu Hause. Wie hieß die Serie? Curb Your Enthusiasm. Magst du kurz eine Zusammenfassung geben? Larry Davids, es ist ungefähr das amerikanische Pastewka, die Vorbildsendung von Pastewka. Ist das eine Vorbildsendung von Pastewka?
Ja, ja, genau. Och Mensch, ey. Was, wieso?
Ich dachte, dass Pastewka was Eigenständiges wäre.
Nein, nichts ist was Eigenständiges. Deutschland hat nichts Eigenständiges.
Ja, aber das ist doch scheiße. Gar nichts. Ich habe immer gesagt
im Ausland, ja, wir haben Tatortreiniger, wir haben Pastewka,
wir haben Stromberg, okay,
wir haben Tatortreiniger und Pastewka, das sind eigentlich die beiden.
Ich bin mir sicher, wenn man lange genug nachforschen würde,
würde man auch das Vorbild von Tatortreiniger finden.
Genau. Von daher kommt man da. Das ist echt traurig, oder? Nicht zustande. Das Podcast-Ufo gibt es so lange noch nicht. Auch in keiner anderer Form. Im ganzen Universum gibt es nur ein Podcast-Ufo. Wir essen die Leberna an. Wir haben sie gekühlt. Hat sogar das William-Mikrophonik in die Leberna angesteckt? Nein. So wahnsinnig. Im Universum gibt es nur ein Podcast-Ufo, was ja auch passt. Wir haben ja diese Weltraumatmosphäre, diese Weltraumästhetik gewählt für unseren Podcast aus gutem Grund, denn wir fühlen uns im Universum zu Hause. Ich bin ein Universums-Free. Die Erde, die Welt kann uns nicht mehr halten. Die Welt ist uns einfach als Spielplatz zu klein geworden. Wir sind expandiert ins Universum. Wir fliegen draußen herum in unserem kleinen Podcast-Ufo, weil wir nicht genug kriegen können. Wir schauen nach vorne, wir wollen weiter, wir wollen gucken, was ist hinter dem Horizont, was ist am anderen Ende des Universums. Und das Universum expandiert ja stetig. Ja. Und das ist etwas, was mich persönlich total freut. Ja. Immer gibt es mehr, immer passiert ein bisschen mehr, alles geht nach vorne. Es wird nie langweilig im Universum. Im Gegenteil, alles wird grösser, alles wird komplexer, alles wird schwieriger durchschauen. Ja. Reflexion ist dadurch sehr wichtig. Hey, und das Universum expandiert, ich kann es nicht auf genug sagen. Und ich habe auch... Der einzige Fakt, den du dir überlegt hast, zu dem Universum ist, das Universum expandiert. Wow. Weißt du, wie man das entdeckt hat, dass das Universum expandiert? Man hat ins All geguckt und alle Galaxien haben roten Schimmer. Und das heisst, rot ist die längste Wellenlänge, die ein Licht hat. Licht ist mein Thema, ich bin ein Lichtfreak. Versuchst du auch jedes Thema einfach zu Licht zu längen. Licht hat auch viele Chancen. Musik ist geil, aber Licht ist auch geil. Und dann rot die längste Wellenlänge. Und was sich wegbewegt, ist der Doppler-Effekt, hat eben die höhere Wellenlänge. Und da alles rot ist um uns herum, dachte man, okay, das bewegt sich weg, das ist plausibel. Wenn es näher kommt, ist es richtig blau, sehr gut. Hey, hui, scheiße. Ich erkläre gerade jemandem, was der mehr von dem Thema versteht als ich. Das ist mein guter Punkt. Nee, ja tatsächlich, also Universum ist ein spannendes Thema und tatsächlich viel passiert. Aber ich finde das ja alles sehr interessant, so diese ganze Physik und so, wie das entdeckt wurde und alles. Ich leg mich mal hin. Aber es gibt ja immer so dieses Zitat so, wenn man in die Sterne schaut, fühlt man sich ganz klein, so in Relation zu den Sternen. Aber es ist auch so. Aber ich hatte dieses Gefühl noch nie. Noch nie. Ich habe mich noch nie klein gefühlt, nur weil es was Größeres als mich gibt. Das ist eine Logik, die ich noch nicht so ganz durchschaut habe.
Natürlich ist man nur sandkornhaft klein im Universum.
Ich bin zwei Meter gross ungefähr.
Aber man lebt ja nicht im Universum, man lebt ja auf der Erde.
Ich bin zwei Meter gross ungefähr und ich sehe mich schon als das Größte, was es gibt auf der Erde, ungefähr.
Und wenn ich in die Weite hinaus sehe und dann sehe ich den Mond zum Beispiel.
Wenn ich den Mond sehe, habe ich immer das Gefühl, das ist ganz schön krass,
dass da so ein Riesending um die Erde fliegt.
Ja.
Mehr fühle ich nicht.
Dann checke ich meine Twitter-Feed, weil ich ein ADHS-Typ bin.
Das ist eigentlich, darum geht es.
Aber ich habe immer das Gefühl, wenn ich auf den Mond geruchte, denke ich mir immer,
wow, das ist ganz schön krass, was es so alles noch gibt.
Und wenn du überlegst, dass eine Sonne halt unfassbar gross ist
und davon Milliarden über Milliarden Sonnen da oben rumstecken, das ist ganz schön krass, was es so alles noch gibt. Und wenn du überlegst, dass eine Sonne halt unfassbar gross ist und davon Milliarden über Milliarden Sonnen da oben rumstecken, das ist ganz schön krass. Ja. Aber guck mal, also manchmal denke ich mir, ich wäre viel lieber in einer Ehrenzeit geboren, zum Beispiel so in den 80ern, weil man da lustig rumlaufen konnte, alle waren gut gelaunt, alle hatten ein bisschen was eingeworfen, Frauen hatten nichts zu sagen, wurden getreten, geil. und jetzt ist alles so auch ganz cool, man hat Zwar vor uns und so, in ein paar Jahren hat man noch coolere Dinge,
aber irgendwann hat man vielleicht, kann man zum Mars fliegen und da sind nur Großeltern besuchen oder so. Ja. Also was es für die auch normal sein wird, ist es nicht dann die uncoolere Zeit, in der wir jetzt leben? Ist nicht jede Zeit cooler als der, in der man jetzt lebt? Ja, eben. Deswegen ergibt es auch keinen Sinn, sich eine andere Zeit zu wünschen eigentlich, oder? Weil selbst wenn du in einer anderen Zeit leben würdest, auch hier dann deine Zeit die uncoolste wäre. Ja, aus eigenem Empfinden. Ja. Aber objektiv betrachtet, ist was die bessere Zeit? Natürlich da, wo die Menschen alle, zum Beispiel Toleranz. Früher haben Frauen keine Rechte gehabt, heute wissen wir, objektiv kann man sagen, dass es Quatsch war. Ja, aber das haben die damals ja objektiv nicht gedacht. Damals haben die damals gesagt, objektiv, die damaligen Stephan und Florentin-Podcast-Ufe-Leute haben wahrscheinlich gesagt, hey, wir sind in unserer Burg, wir hassen Frauen und das ist voll objektiv auch richtig betrachtet und okay so. Ja, aber das ist doch heutzutage auch anders. Vielleicht gibt es auch eine objektiv beste Zeit der Welt, in der man leben kann. Aber es entwickelt sich halt immer weiter, es wird immer, immer besser. Es hört nie auf, besser zu werden. Und irgendwann sind die Frauen die neuen Männer. Ja, vielleicht. Wenn das objektiv besser ist, als wie es jetzt ist, vielleicht, ja, man weiß es nicht. Glaubst du, es ist immer objektiver wird alles? Nein, ich glaube, es geht schon bergauf und bergab. Also ich meine, man sieht ja im Mittelalter und so, da gingen ja die ganzen Errungenschaften von der Antike mehr oder weniger kaputt und alles.
Da ging es wieder bergab und alles wieder religiöser Fanatismus.
Trotzdem eine Zeit, die man sehr interessant findet.
Ja, klar, natürlich, irgendwo schon.
Aber es ist halt schwer zu sagen.
Das hat auch nichts mit dem Thema Universum zu tun.
Ich habe mir vier Universums-Gags aufgeschrieben, die würde ich jetzt schon langsam mal gerne unterbringen.
Du hast echt Gags aufgeschrieben?
Nein, ich habe mir keine Gags aufgeschrieben, tatsächlich.
Ich wollte nur sagen, dass dieses, es ist halt einfach unglaublich, Universum. Danke. Für diese Einschätzung. Captain of Jesus ist auch da. Es ist einfach unglaublich. Wofür glauben wir das jetzt? Ich weiß es nicht. Universum ist halt so ein scheiß grobes Thema, weil es halt einfach alles beinhaltet. Ja, wir haben aber GoButler gefragt, die werden aber besser wissen als wir. Aber wenn fucking GoButler, sie sollte einfach nicht die Themen auswählen tatsächlich. Das ist halt einfach vielleicht die Lehre, die wir heute gezogen haben, dass im ganzen Universum jeder hätte uns ein Thema beitragen. Wir haben ein Scheißthema gewählt, da haben wir gesagt, komm, ab jetzt nie wieder Scheißthemen, zieh uns eine Woche lang durch und die nächsten überwerfen wir alles über Bord. Aber letzte Woche hatten wir die Idee, dass Hörer uns Voicemail schicken können. Ja, das ist nicht passiert. Wollen wir da mal kurz gucken, was eigentlich ist. Wir hören mal ganz kurz rein, was eigentlich ist. Warte und bitteschön. Ja, das waren alle, glaube ich. Das waren alle. Ja, vielen Dank dafür. Wir hoffen, dass es nicht abreißt und dass wir uns weiterhin so tolle Sachen schicken. War unser Fehler aber auch. Man kann bei Skype nämlich keine Voicemails hinterlassen. Ja, es war ein bisschen unser Fehler tatsächlich. Wollen wir uns ein Handy kaufen denn oder ist das zu schein? Nein, ja, ich weiß nicht. Von dem Geld, was uns gespendet wurde vielleicht. Keine Ahnung, das regt mich auch schon wieder alles auf. Da bin ich technisch schon wieder an meine Grenzen gestossen, diese ganze Skype-Scheiße. Das macht mich wahnsinnig. Ja, nein, nein, da werde ich emotional. Das will ich nicht. Bitte, bitte, bitte. Ich habe heute tatsächlich kein Equipment mitgenommen, kein Kabel. Und mir ist eingefallen, mich damals, ich bin ja immer, ich fahre ja immer montags extrem früh von Berlin nach Köln, also mitten in der Nacht. Und das ist immer so eine Art Delirium, so eine Art Albtraum, wo ich irgendwo drin bin, weil man wacht auf, man ist zwischen wach und schlafend und wandelt dann so durch die Gassen. Und dann habe ich mir tatsächlich, weil ich jetzt keine Jacke mehr mitgenommen habe, weil es warm ist, und sonst habe ich immer die Jacke auf mich draufgelegt und über meinen Kopf gelegt, so dass ich nichts mehr sehe, damit ich besser schlafen kann im Zug. Und jetzt hatte ich meine Jacke nicht dabei. Kapuze, Kapuze. Ich konnte nichts über mich sehen, aber die Kapuze reicht ja nicht bis ins Gesicht. Ich kann ja auch nicht zu viel um mein Gesicht nehmen, sonst ist meine Frisur wieder... Und ich will doch gar nicht wissen, was in der Kapuze alles drin ist, weil er hat nur einen Pulli, muss man Marco sagen. Ja, genau. Da sammelt sich schon einiges an. Einen einzigen Pulli, der ist braun. Das ist so ein bisschen der Bauchnabel meiner Garderobe. Und alle werden jetzt sagen, wenn Florentin ein Bildschirm mal gesehen hat, er hat immer einen braunen Pulli an. Ja, klar. Es sei denn, er bekommt irgendwie für Auftritte in der Fernsehsendung ein anderes Kostüm rausgelegt. Ja, ich will, wenn ich groß bin, in der Zeichenregelserie arbeiten. Und deswegen habe ich mich jetzt schon mal darauf vorbereitet, dass ich jeden Tag dasselbe Kostüm anhabe. Deswegen. Das macht das mit einem. Ist es nicht wahnsinnig auch problematisch, Klamotten zu kaufen? Nee, es ist extrem einfach, Klamotten zu kaufen. Willst du dein Leben lang anhaben, ab jetzt? Nein, das ändert sich ja schon. Es gibt ja immer so verschiedene Lebensphasen, wo man das dann ändert, aber an sich versuche ich möglichst wenig. Wie lange trägst du jetzt mit deinen, du hast fünf diese Pullis, sagen wir mal, du hast fünf braune Pullis, die genau identisch sind. Also wie oft, sagen wir mal, wie lange trägst du das jetzt oder wie lange trägst du das schon in dem Outfit? Ja, halt seit gestern, so zwei, drei Tage vielleicht. Aber nur braun. Braun hast du schon seit mindestens einem Monat immer. Ja, das schon, ja. Aber wie lange das schon? Ja, jetzt halt, ja, einen Monat ungefähr. Okay. Und irgendwann ändert sich das wieder. Ich versuche halt einfach so wenig Aufmerksamkeit wie möglich in meiner Garderobe zu stecken, wie möglich, weil ich mich damit nicht beschäftigen will. Das ist eine Lebenseinstellung, wenn du dann in den Laden gehst. Dann sagst du, will ich den Pulli oder den Pulli? Meine Lebenseinstellung... Ich werde das drei Monate lang am Stück tragen. Meine Lebenseinstellung ist, wenn ich in den Laden gehe, ist, ich will sofort wieder raus. Ich hasse nichts mehr als Kleider. Es ist die Hölle auf Erden. Es ist furchtbar. Warum? Weil es schrecklich ist, weil ich mich da überhaupt nicht wohlfühle. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich kann mich mit den Menschen nicht identifizieren. Ich will nicht angesprochen werden, ich will nicht, dass Leute mir dabei zuschauen, wie ich mir irgendwelche Sachen angucke. Ich will nicht, dass Leute mir dabei zuschauen, wie ich mir überlege, wie ich aussehen möchte. Das will ich einfach nicht. Aber ich habe auch noch nicht irgendwie komplett durchstiegen, wie das mit diesem Internet funktioniert. Du hast ein Problem, mit Eitelkeit umzugehen? Ja, absolut, klar. Das ist einfach für mich eine Situation, in der ich mich nicht wohlfühle und ich will nicht, dass mir so Leute in der Situation, in der ich mich nicht wohlfühle, zuschauen. Oh, wunderbar. Deswegen zum Beispiel, nee, ich hasse es auch, da mit Verkäufern zu interagieren und ich verstecke mich teilweise wirklich vor den Verkäufern, weil ich das so unangenehm finde, wenn jemand auf mich zukommt und sagt, kann ich Ihnen helfen oder sowas. Wollen wir mal durchspielen? Wir haben so eine gute Beziehung zu Hörspielen. Okay, kann ich Ihnen helfen vielleicht? Nee, danke, ich gucke noch. Immer das Gleiche. Ich schreibe irgendwann die Leute schon an, wenn ich im fünften Laden bin und die Leute sprechen mich an, nein, ich will nicht geholfen werden! Ja, nee, ich tatsächlich, also auch zum Beispiel, wenn ich Kleidung anprobiere, verlasse ich niemals die Umkleidekabine. Würde ich niemals machen. Ich bleibe in der Umkleidekabine, ziehe die Sachen an, merke, okay, ich bin zu fett, ziehe die Sachen wieder aus und das war's. Ich verlasse nie die Umkleidekabine, wie normale Menschen, die dann in dieser Gasse, in diesem Vorhof dann rumstolzieren und dann sich mit ihrer Frau streiten. Ich nie, ich bleibe immer in der Kabine drin. Bei mir ist es häufig so, dass ich, weil ich habe sehr lange Beine und deswegen ist es häufig so, dass, das hat absolut keinen Sinn, dass ich sehr lange in der Kabine bleiben muss. Manchmal sind Hosen zu eng, hätte man einfach so anfangen können. Und dann habe ich immer ein Problem damit. Es liegt aber auch in einem riesengroßen Penis. Ich habe einen wahnsinnig großen Penis. Und dann gehe ich auch damit raus. Also wenn ich die Hose nicht zubekomme, würde ich auch rausgehen. Ja klar, natürlich. Aus Pfannen zeigen, dass ich die Hose nicht anbekommen habe. Wie ist es bei öffentlichen Toiletten mit dir? Sehr, sehr gut. Da habe ich sehr gute Erfahrungen damit gemacht, tatsächlich. Ich liebe öffentliche Toiletten. Ja, liebe ich. Kriege ich nicht genug von. Also ich würde mich immer für die öffentliche Toilette entscheiden, wenn ich die Wahl hätte, zwischen privater und öffentlicher. Nee, aber ist tatsächlich, finde ich furchtbar und deswegen finde ich es immer ganz gut, wenn ich schon weiss, genau was ich kaufe und auch schon genau weiss, wo die Sachen sind, die ich kaufen will und ich gehe einfach rein, grab it, leave und das war's. Würde ich auch nie anders machen. Warum machst du nicht im Internet? Einfach Internet ist das auch cool. Ja, das weiss ich immer auch nicht genau, weil dann sieht es immer anders aus, dann weiss ich nicht, wie die Farbe aussieht, dann hat man immer so ein Bild im Kopf und dann denkt man, das sieht ganz anders aus und dann sieht man wieder aus wie der letzte Vollidiot. Das ist nicht das Braun, was ich mir vorgehe. Das ist auch braun, das ist auch so eine Farbe, wie entscheidet man sich aktiv im braunen Pulli zu kaufen. Nein, ich habe mal irgendjemanden gesehen, wo ich mir dachte, ach, das sieht doch ganz okay aus, der einen braunen Pulli anhatte und dann habe ich, nein, es ist einfach, ich möchte mit meiner Garderobe so wenig wie möglich auffallen. Das ist meine Intention.
Gut, dass wir jetzt darüber reden wie im öffentlichen Podcast.
Nein, aber es gibt ja viele Leute, die wollen sich durch ihre Kleidung abheben und auffallen.
Und bei mir ist es ein exaktes Gegenteil.
Am liebsten würde ich einen Tarnanzug tragen, wenn es mich nicht auffälliger machen würde als jetzt,
weil ich damit einfach nicht mich identifizieren kann.
Wie cool wäre eigentlich ein Tarnanzug.
Wäre eigentlich schon ziemlich cool.
Wie cool.
Ich hatte als Kind ein Tarnnetz, da hatten wir mal so einen Militärkatalog rumfliegen bei uns in der Wohnung, warum auch immer. Und dann durfte sich jeder irgendwas aus dem Militärkatalog bestellen. Militärkatalog? Ja, why? Und irgendwie, ich wollte halt klar, ein MiG-29 war dann tatsächlich zu teuer. Was ist ein Flugzeug, ein russisches Flugzeug. Und ich dachte, du bist Flugzeugfan. Hier hat mir heute die ganze Zeit Fotos gezeigt von sich und seiner Freundin früher, wie sie auch irgendwie Planespotting begangen haben auf einem Flughafen. Nein, ich kenne mich da nicht aus. Auf jeden Fall, nee, auf jeden Fall durfte sich an jeder... Hast du dir das rausgeschrieben? Hast du dir das rausgeschrieben? Hast du extra ein Modell rausgeschrieben aus dem Internet, was du mir jetzt sagst? Nein, MiG-29, da war ich früher Fan davon, war früher mein Lieblingsflugzeug, MiG-29. Ich kenne mich nicht davon. Auf jeden Fall, wo waren wir gerade? ach ja, die Militärzeitschrift, durfte sich jeder was aussuchen, mein Bruder irgendwie ein Messer oder sowas, coole Sachen, der war auch schon älter, ich bin der jüngste von meinen Brüdern und ich hatte mir ein Tarnnetz.
Was hat der denn den coole Bruder, der dich immer verarscht hat, was hat der denn, was hat der denn sich bestellt?
Der hat ein Messer, habe ich ja gerade eben gesagt, der hat sich ein Messer bestellt und der andere, keine Ahnung, irgendwie Tarnfarbe oder irgendwas anderes und ich hatte halt so ein Tarnnetz, was halt so ein grünes Netz war, wo so Tarnflecken eingearbeitet wurden. Wo ich in normalen Wohnungen wahnsinnig aufwendig mit essen. Und dann bin ich sofort, als das Tarnnetz angekommen ist, bin ich mit diesem relativ schweren Ding sofort in den Wald gelaufen, hab mich getarnt und hab's dann direkt verloren, weil ich es nicht mehr gefunden hab. Aber es war sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gut. Also Kundenreferenzierung, sehr, sehr gutes Tarnitz, ich habe es instant verloren. Es war sofort weg. Ich habe es in die Wiese gelegt und es war weg. Es war sofort mit dem Buch verschmolzen. Wieso findet man, also der Tarnumhang von Harry Potter. Ja. Ist es eigentlich, was ist eine Nebenfrage, ist es eines der Heiligtümer des Todes? Ja. Aber es wird nie in den Filmen, wirdab und... In den Filmen wird nie zum Thema gemacht, dass er eines, also da bekommt er diese Geschichte vorgelesen von Hermine, und da wird gesagt, ja, es gibt den Tannumhang, es gibt diesen Älterstab und es gibt den Stein der Wiederaufstehung. Und er hat aber nie gesagt, oh, hey, geil, einen habe ich ja schon. Das kommt mir sehr bekannt vor. Moment, dieser Umhang, von dem du gerade gesprochen hast, hier ist er, hier ist er, hat er nie gesagt. Nee, er hat einfach gerade gedöst. Aber ich finde, das macht solche Filme realistischer. Man sagt ja immer, der Film ist unrealistisch, weil man hätte an dem Zeitpunkt schon sagen können, das ist meiner, aber so funktioniert die Welt nicht. Es ist oft so, dass Leute irgendwie verloren und wollen nicht zugeben, wenn man verloren hat. Apropos Umhang. Wo ist eigentlich dieser Unsichtbarkeitsumhang? Hatte ich mal ein? Ich das? Nee, das heißt ja nicht irgendwie... Da waren wir nur betrunken und dachten, wir wären unsichtbar, wir waren gar nicht wirklich unsichtbar. Aber es ist im echten Leben auch, dass man einem davon erzählt, dass man jetzt ein Auto hat und man hört einfach nicht zu. Und Tage später sagt man, oh, du hast ja ein neues Auto und dann hat man es gar nicht mitbekommen. Wie ich eben mit dem Messer und deinem Bruder. Zum Beispiel, genau das passiert in Filmen auch manchmal. Das ist unabsichtlich dann. Ja, unabsichtlich, ja, tatsächlich. Aber, naja, Harry Potter. Ist auch eine Folge wert, Harry Potter. Aber ist es, glaube ich, ist es, also meinst du, es gibt ja diesen Wunsch, unsichtbar zu sein, ne? Das ist ja so eine grundmenschliche Konstante eigentlich, so bei den Superheldenkräften immer ganz weit oben. Aber es gibt keinen bekannten Superhelden, der unsichtbar werden kann, oder? Das stimmt. Doch, es gibt Invisibility Girl. Oder die waren in allen Comics, man hat sie aber nur nie gesehen. Genau, und die Schauspielerin wurde auch extrem schlecht bezahlt. Das ist gut. Auch für Lebensläufe, einfach so schreiben. Ja, genau. Ja, ich war der Unsichtbarkeitsheld in allen Batman-Filmen, in allen mit Nolan auch gut gedreht. Cooler Typ. Ich habe in dem Wo ist Waldo-Film mitgespielt. Vielleicht haben Sie mich gesehen im Hintergrund. Vielleicht auch nicht. Nein, aber das ist ja so eine grundmenschliche Konstante, dass man unsichtbar sein möchte. Glaubst du, das war im Mittelalter auch schon so, wenn im Mittelalter Kinder gefragt haben, was würdest du, lieber fliegen oder unsichtbar, oder ist das eher ein moderner Gedanke, weil man so mit Tarnkappentechnologie überhaupt erst die Idee des Unsichtbarseins... Unsichtbarkeit ist ja auch nicht so ein Ding, entweder man ist da oder nicht da, das ist halt ein grundlegendes Existenzding, wo ich glaube, dass es schon relativ früh Menschen das Bedürfnis gehabt haben, einfach weg zu sein. Ja, aber wirklich jetzt unsichtbar, also im Sinne von irgendwie halt, dass man nicht gesehen werden kann, aber trotzdem noch agieren kann, also trotzdem noch Frauen anschauen kann, aber unsichtbar sein kann. Ich glaube doch. Harry Potter ist ja auch aus der Bibel gekommen. Ist abgeleitet worden, ja. Die zweite Ableitung der Bibel ist Harry Potter. Zweite Ableitung, sehr gut. Kleinen Mathematiker-Gag reingebracht, um die Mathematiker reinzuholen. Ja, die Mathematiker ist alles das Wichtigste. Das ist tatsächlich so. Die Mathematiker und die Informatiker muss man immer ganz nah an seinem Podcast halten, weil die programmieren irgendwelche Viren und verteilen seine Podcasts. Und Grafiker. Ja, auch ganz wichtig. Falls ihr mal wieder ein neues Logo wollt, was unwahrscheinlich ist. Falls ihr euch wundert, warum neulich unser Logo gelb war, es war, ja, gelb Tag, es war Gelbsucht. Du wieder was aus der Dropbox gelöscht hast, wo ich mich immer, wenn Leute was aus der Dropbox löschen, fragen, warum löscht man überhaupt Dinge aus der Dropbox? Ich hasse die Dropbox. Die nehmen immer so viel Speicherplatz, da lösche ich was und dann ist man aufgefahren, oh okay, es ist halt überall. Ja genau, man hat immer irgendwie 400 Megabyte von 800 Gigabyte und denkt sich, warum habe ich so viel Speicherplatz gekauft? Man agiert dann doch halt immer sehr oft sehr egozentristisch und denkt dann halt, wenn ich es bei mir lösche, ist es halt bei mir weg. Aber es ist bei allen anderen auch weg, das ist auch so ein typisches Zeichen. Wenn Weintrauben hier liegen, kann man viel falsch machen. Wenn Weintrauben, ein bisschen die Sinnlichkeit wollten wir heute zelebrieren. Ich dachte eigentlich auch, dass wir zu zweit auf dem Sofa sitzen oder liegen, ist nicht der Fall. Ich sitze ihm gegenüber auf einem harten Stuhl, während Stefanie sich auf der Couch räkelt alleine. Ach, wie geil das ist, wenn wir nebeneinander säßen in einem Raum und in eine Richtung gucken. Das wäre echt cool. Das ist ja auch die Frage, wenn man sich mit Leuten trifft, so Date oder sowas, wie setzt man sich hin? Das ist so lustig. Immer so kommen wir die Folgen, einfach nebeneinander zu sitzen und leer in eine Richtung zu starren. Das ist ja aber geil. Irgendwann wird man ja sehr alt.
Ist das so?
Wenn man Sätze einfach nicht zu Ende spricht,
der Anfang lustiger ist, dass das Ende.
Wenn man irgendwann sehr alt wird, dann gibt es ja auch diese Cafés, wenn man halt so bei
Kurstätten oder halt so Badeorten ist.
Ja. Zum Beispiel, wo ich mal früher war,
Timdorfer Strand, da gab es dann immer geile
Cafés, wo einfach sehr viele
alte Menschen saßen, die in die gleiche Richtung geguckt haben
und immer so den Leuten hergeguckt haben, die gerade
die Promenade entlang laufen. Und man alle,
man geht entlang und dann sieht man, wie ich bei einem Tennis-Match
Vielen Dank. geile Cafés, wo einfach sehr viele alte Menschen saßen, die in die gleiche Richtung geguckt haben und immer so den Leuten hergeguckt haben, die gerade die Promenade entlang laufen und alle, man geht entlang und dann sieht man mit dem Tennis Match die ganzen Augen, gucken die man nicht an, das ist echt lustig. Und das ist so die, ich glaube, je älter man wird, umso lieber guckt man in eine Richtung. Ja, auch manchmal. So lieber synchronisiert man das, glaube ich. Aber zum Beispiel auch einfach die unangenehmste Gesprächssituation ist drei Leute an der an der Bar ist, finde ich, das schlimmste, was man haben kann. Oder vier Leute an der Bar, wenn einfach drei Leute an der Bar sitzen und einfach zwei in der Mitte unterhalten sich und die außen dann so, ja, cool, kann ich noch mal eine Salzschange haben? Du musst ja schon sehr laut sprechen. Ja. Und der in der Mitte, wenn die über ihren Job reden und der in der Mitte nicht mitreden kann, dann wird über den in den Blick gesprochen. Stefan war gerade so aufgeregt und zittrig, dass sein Mikrofon aus dem Hand gefallen ist,
weil er endlich mal was sagen kann, dass er Erfahrungen mit sozialer Interaktion hat. Ich kann zeigen, ich habe Freunde, ich kann zeigen, ich war auch schon mal in einer Bar. Wie Kommunikation in den Bars schief geht. Darum kenne ich mich sehr gut aus. Genau, ja. Man ist immer die Person außen. Das ist ja auch eigentlich immer eher zufällig, wo man an so einem Tisch sitzt, aber immer die sozialen Idioten sitzen auch immer an den dummen Stellen. Also das gehört genauso zum sozialen Feindgefühl. Ich bin sehr schnell schlecht gelaunt, wenn ich auf den falschen Plätzen sitze. Ich bin am Anfang immer sehr bewusst achte ich darauf, wo ich mich hinsetze. Ich fahre mich nicht, ob es mir nur mir so geht. Also ich versuche das tatsächlich auch immer. Und zum Beispiel jetzt bald... Aber wir sind auch beide socially sehr awkward. Ja, aber deswegen, je mehr man socially awkward ist, desto mehr muss man ja dagegen arbeiten. Desto mehr, selbstreflektiert, ist man sich das Problem sehr bewusst und weiss, man ist socially awkward und muss dem möglichst gute Situationen schaffen. Nicht jetzt wie Dave, der irgendwie von der anderen Tischseite irgendwie noch Annika beeindrucken kann, weil er irgendwie Salzstangen auf sie wirft oder was. Die coolsten Namen, die dir eingefallen sind. Okay, jetzt auch mal, Dave war ein bisschen zu cool. Ja. Bleiben wir auf dem Boden, Annika. Aber was ist denn ein cooler weiblicher Name? Charlotte? Lynn. Lynn. Lynn? Zoe. Ist Zoe cool? Na, man weiß es nicht. Aber zum Beispiel, jetzt bald habe ich ein Treffen mit einigen Leuten und ich weiß, dass ich zwei Stunden zu spät komme. Und ich weiß jetzt schon genau, wie es aussehen wird. Du überlegst jetzt schon genau, wie du dich hinsetzt. Ja, genau, ich überlege mir jetzt schon, ob ich im Vorhinein nicht sagen soll, also, hey, wir sind ja gute Freunde und so, könnt ihr vielleicht irgendwie einen coolen Platz für mich freilhalten, weil es kommt unser innerer Freundeskern, den wir uns schon ewig kennen und noch ein paar andere Leute. Und ich weiß genau, wie es aussehen wird, der innere Freundeskern sitzt in der Mitte irgendwie cool zusammen und hat Party und außenrum so wie bei so einem Gangbang, so die unattraktiveren Männer sind immer weiter außen. Wie eine Zwiebel, nach außen wird es immer angegriffen. Du sagst Zwiebel, ich sag wie ein Gangbang aufgebaut, wo man auch immer so merkt, wo man in einem Gangbang kann man immer genau merken, wie gut man ist, je weiter man außen steht. Das ist bestimmt genau dasselbe wie bei einem sozialen Gefüge, ist auch ein Gangbang, wo du merkst, okay, ich bin in der dritten Linie und hol mir gerade einen runter, ich werde wahrscheinlich heute nicht mehr zum Zug kommen. Weißt du auch genau, wo du bist einfach? Du kannst es genau abhängig machen. Je weiter weg von der Frau du bist, desto schlechter bist du einfach. Daran kann man es genau ablesen. Und jetzt habe ich diese Situation Oder eben die Torte. Nee, nee, Torte funktioniert. Danke trotzdem für deinen Beitrag. Aber jetzt habe ich auch bei so einer Situation, ich weiss genau, wie es ablaufen wird. Ich komme zu spät und na, hol dir noch einen Stuhl aus dem Keller und ja, oder setze dich auf Skateboard, okay. Oder geh doch einfach wieder nach Hause, du bist jetzt zu spät, lohnt gar nicht mehr. Oder geh doch wieder nach Hause, ja, was, okay, cool, ja. Aber ich glaube, der Auftritt ist alles. Also das sage ich mir immer, der Auftritt ist alles. Wenn du zu spät kommst, ist schon mal ein bisschen cool, weil du stehst im Mittelpunkt plötzlich. Leute reagieren auf dich, Leute müssen aufstehen, um dich zu begrüssen, Mädchen stehen auf, um dich zu umarmen. Du bist aber auch tatsächlich immer sehr fordernd, also mir fällt gerade ein, du stellst dich hier so da als, oh ja, dann kriege ich keinen Sitzplatz mehr. In der Redaktion ist es immer so, ich komme zweieinhalb Stunden früher, komme extra noch vor Redaktionsbeginn, setze mich hin und Stefan kommt an, ne, ich sitze hier, ich sitze hier, ich bin im E-Mail-Verteiler, du nicht, steh auf, so, herrschte mich an und man muss dir dann auch gehorchen. Das ist genau dein Wunderpunkt, du warst einmal im E-Mail-Verteiler letzte Woche und das war richtig angegessen. Wenn alle im E-Mail-Verteiler sind, tut man selber nicht, das ist einfach eine dumme Situation. Ja, das ist Mobbing. Es gab in einer Firma, gab es eine Internliste. Eine Internliste und ich war festangestellt hier und habe schon ein Jahr her gearbeitet und dann kamen Praktikanten plötzlich an. Hey, geile Story da! Und ich so, ganz kurz, was ist gerade passiert? Ja, in der Internliste, voll geil. Ach so, das meinst du, ja, ja, total gut. Ja, genau, warum bin ich noch nicht, ich arbeite ein bisschen festangestellt, ein bisschen Praktikant. Ja. Aber mittlerweile bin ich in der internen Liste. Mittlerweile, ja, gut, ich nicht. So, naja, auf jeden Fall. Der Auftritt, der Auftritt ist alles. Ja, aber du kriegst keinen Auftritt hin, dass du Leute vom Stuhl aufscheuchen kannst, oder? Also ich meine, benutze dann die Situation, dass irgendwie Melinda aufsteht, um dich zu umarmen, und du im gleichen Atemzug sie umarmst, dich einmal drehst, vielleicht im Takt der Musik so ein bisschen, oh, wir tanzen, drehst dich, setzt dich auf ihren Platz und übernimmst direkt ihr Essen und machst dann so weiter. Das wäre der coolste Move der Welt. Das wäre ein ziemlich cooler Move. Probiert das mal aus. Fürs Wochenende bitte probiert mal Folgendes aus und nehmt euch in einer Party, klaut einfach mal einen Platz. Das ist unsere Aufgabe an die Podcast-Ufo-Hörer. Klaut einen Platz auf einer Party. Und nehmt es auf und schickt es uns also Wein. Bei Skype, als Voicemail. Genau, per E-Mail. Bitte in RAR-Format verpackt. Und nicht zu viele Zips bitte. Das ist immer verwirklich. Ich liebe Zips. Zips ist auch das Geilste der Welt. Ich habe aber nicht ganz verstanden, wenn man die entpackt. Ja. Sind die dann zweimal auf dem Rechner, einmal in Perfekt. Ich glaube schon, ja. Aber ich habe immer gedacht, okay, hat sich gerade vermehrt. Und wenn ich da jetzt an und draufliege, vermehrt sich immer weiter. Es ist ein bisschen unangenehm, da gerade bei zugeschaut zu haben, so, oh, was ist da gerade passiert? So, oh, sorry, Leute, da wollte ich jetzt aber gerade. Das wollte ich damit nicht auswirken. Ja, ja, genau. Ich glaube auch, 80% meiner Festplatte sind unausgepackte SIP-Dateien. Und ist das schlimm überhaupt, weil die sind ja sehr klein. Ja, so klein sind die auch nicht. Das ist auch ein Mythos, dass die SIP-Dateien sind. Das ist ein bisschen ein Mythos. So 500 Megabyte komprimiert, 470. Man ist ja so, naja, ist das jetzt so gut, man weiß es nicht. Du hast die Podcast-Folge mal einmal in einer SIP-Datei hochgeladen und es war exakt genau so. Es war exakt genau so. Es hat nichts gebracht, nichts. Es ist einfach nur gefaked, ja. Was macht denn diese Datei überhaupt? Die faltet das zusammen, die legt das zusammen so. Aber es ist trotzdem, wenn man jetzt mal in der Physik bleibt, trotzdem noch genauso dicht, nee, die Dichte wird grösser, es ist genauso schwer. Also es ist netto genau das Gleiche, eigentlich. Ja, aber ich würde sagen, es ist dieselbe Masse, aber nicht dasselbe Volumen. Die Dichte nimmt schon ab. Zum Beispiel, wenn du ein T-Shirt hast. Nee, ab. Je kleiner man Dinge faltet, die gleich sind, nimmt die Dichte zu. Ja, deswegen nimmt sie ja ab, wenn man... Ach ja, du hast recht. Also wenn du zum Beispiel ein T-Shirt in der zusammengefalteten Fassung kannst du nicht anziehen.
Und genauso ist die Sippdatei.
Die Sippdatei ist vom Volumen her reduziert, aber du kannst sie nicht benutzen.
Du musst sie erst, wenn du die Sippdatei eröffnest, entfalten, das T-Shirt aufmachen, dann kannst du es anziehen.
Das heißt, für den Transport legst du dein T-Shirt zusammen oder zur Lagerung.
Aber an sich, die Masse des T-Shirts verändert sich nicht, der Informationsgehalt ist der selbe. Es war sehr anschaulich, du hast auch sehr gestikuliert gerade. Liebe Leute, die kriegst du nachher als GIF zugeschickt. Ja, genau. Als Zip. Als Zip-GIF, ja. Aber ich muss auch noch ein Video machen von dem Sassy-Anti-Mobbing- Stimmt. Damit ihr euch das vorstellen könnt. Halt, stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt, mein Niveau, dein Nive nicht, ich glaube, ich habe sie gemobbt, glaube ich. Ich glaube, ich habe sie gemobbt. Da sind ihr geschlafen. Ich habe ihr geschlafen, muss ihr ja gesagt. Genau, sie konnte es nicht anders verarbeiten, als das. Ja, Mobbing, oder? Das ist schon Mobbing, gehört schon dazu. Während des Geschlechtsverkehrs hat sie einen Kanzler aufgeführt. Genau, habe ich aber tatsächlich noch geiler gemacht. Von daher hat es nicht so ganz funktioniert. Ich stehe da total drauf, auf solche choreografierten Tänze. Wer hat den Sex, finde ich immer total gut. Du liebst das ja auch Musicals. Du willst doch nicht ohne reingehen. Ich liebe Choreografien einfach. Ich finde es grossartig. Ich finde es egal, in welcher Situation Choreografien sind immer etwas Tolles. Und die hat mir das gesagt und ich konnte es wirklich nicht fassen. Ich habe einfach das Leben von diesem jungen Menschen an mir vorbeiziehen sehen, wie in verschiedenen Situationen irgendwie Schützengraben, Stalingrad, irgendwie der Russe kommt um die Ecke und sie macht diesen Tanz. Mein Niveau und dein Niveau. Hallo, Abstand und wird sofort erschossen. Ach, die Kopfbewegung. Ja, sehr gut. Ach, die Kopfbewegung, das ist ja toll. Ja, das ist auch eine Choreografie. Mach doch mal vor. Ich finde, es sollte im Leben viel mehr Choreografien geben, also so irgendwie coole Handschläge, irgendwie so kleine Tänze, die man vollführt, so Rituale irgendwie, wenn jemand was Gutes gemacht hat, dass man dann so ein kleines Tänzchen hinlegt. Das finde ich, sollte es viel mehr geben. Ja, das stimmt. Die Menschheit braucht Choreografie, braucht Synchronität. Man muss sich auch mal synchron schalten, dass sich einfach zwei Menschen auch miteinander bewegen, was zusammen erreichen und nicht immer nur man alleine sein eigenes Ding macht. Das hat die moderne Welt so ein bisschen verloren, diesen Gedanken der Gemeinschaft, dieses wir gehören zusammen. Vor allem, ich finde auch komisch, abends geht man weg, in Discos zum Beispiel. Ja, in Dissen, glaube ich, sagt man heutzutage. In Disken. Ja, ja. Und ich habe nicht ganz verstanden. Warum? Warum? Hat sie mir doch nicht erschlossen. Ich stehe, mir erschliess es einfach nicht. Es treffen sich sehr viele Menschen da. Ja. An einem Ort, der für sehr viele Menschen relativ zu klein ist, würde ich sagen. Mhm. Und die reden auch nicht miteinander, sondern die tanzen. Okay. Wirklich? Okay, ich sehe das, weil es mir auch so... Ich habe mal ein Duker darüber gelesen. Ja, also es ist tatsächlich so und ich hatte auch mal... Es ist tatsächlich so. Ich habe auch ein Duker darüber gelesen. Ja, tatsächlich, als ich das auch das erste Mal tanzen war oder ob man das so gemacht hat, war bei mir so, ich habe getanzt, zehn Minuten lang, dachte ich mir, okay, gut, passt, dann, so und ciao, können wir gehen. Du, nee, wir tanzen jetzt die ganze Nacht, Moment mal, was, die ganze Nacht, ja, wir sind jetzt sechs Stunden immer noch hier, so, bitte was, sechs Stunden lang, was macht man denn bitte sechs Stunden lang am Stück, nichts, das ist genauso, wenn man sich irgendwie treffen würde und man sagt, wir spielen jetzt sechs Stunden lang Mikado, und reden dabei nicht, man red nicht. Ja. Ich glaube, wir sind beide so kommunikative Menschen. Ja, natürlich. Ich gehe lieber in eine Bar und rede mit Menschen, als in eine Disco zu gehen und mit Leuten nicht zu reden. Ja, absolut. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, also tanzen wird ja auch irgendwann, kommt man in so eine Trance, in so ein Runner's High irgendwie. Wenn man zwei Stunden lang getanzt hat. Ja, du trinkst auch keinen Alkohol. Ja, das stimmt tatsächlich. Das ist doch echt ein Ding. Aber man muss sich seinen Alkoholersatz selber schaffen. Man macht das halt dann durch Endorphine und tanzt und Schwe und trinkt auch viel von seinem eigenen Schweiss. Und ich weiss, es gab mal eine Situation, wo ich irgendwie total abgegangen bin und irgendwie schon zwei Stunden lang getanzt hatte und total im Groove drin war. Und es war mein Song und alles und ich war total in Trance und total abgegangen. Was war es? Hätten wir wieder mal teilen von mir. Ja, genau. Vielleicht du move it, move it. Das ist mein Jam. Das ist mein Jam. Turn it up, turn it up. Genau, und dann war ich so getanzt und war total drin und irgendwann gucke ich hoch und ich merke, dass ich um mich so ein kleiner Kreis gebildet habe und drei Leute mit ihrem Handy mich filmen. Oh Gott. Und ich gucke und sagte, what? Und ich dachte mir wirklich, das war eigentlich ein der unangenehmste Momente meines Lebens, weil ich irgendwie dachte, am nächsten Tag auf YouTube irgendwie Fat Ugly German Kid Dancing irgendwie. Das war echt so unangenehm. Moment meines Lebens war ich irgendwie, ich dachte, am nächsten Tag auf YouTube irgendwie, fat, ugly, German kid dancing irgendwie. Das war echt so unangenehm. Das gibt's ja nicht. Ja, das war echt unangenehm. Aber ich hatte das nicht bemerkt. Ich war irgendwie so drin und im Groove, ich habe das gar nicht bemerkt. Aber es war komisch. Auch vor allem, also ich bin jetzt, sag ich mal, ein Mensch. Bist du so ein geiles Internet-Meme in Albanien? Kann gut sein. Du bist mal gefeiert. Genau, ich kann mir immer vorstellen, wenn ich irgendwann nach Tunesien komme und die Leute vergöttern mich und so, ah, du bist doch Fat Danzig. Wir fangen an Bilder von dir zu machen. Ja, ja, ja. Ich bin jetzt ein Mensch, der sich nicht so leicht tut mit dem schönen Geschlecht im generellen und deswegen habe ich auch dieses Konzept von Schönes Geschlecht? Hunde. Ah ja. Und deswegen hat mir auch dieses Konzept mit Leuten zu tanzen. Ich kann auch nicht mehr Gags über Frauen machen. Man merkt schon einfach Symptom Nummer eins. Er ist doch schlankartig rot geworden. Ich darf nie länger als drei Sekunden über Frauen nachdenken, sonst kollabiere ich komplett. Und deswegen habe ich auch das Konzept von mit anderen Leuten tanzen noch nie so hundertprozentig verstanden. Also ich kann so Standardtänze und so und Foxtrot würde ich hinkriegen, kriege ich alles hin, aber so in einem Club irgendwie updancen, so dieses irgendwie sexuell antanzen, habe ich nie verstanden. Auch wenn Frauen das bei mir gemacht haben, habe ich immer so, ich muss leider los, tut mir leid. Ich hab noch was am Herd. Ich bin ja nur beruflich. Wups. Aber man kann ja, das ist ja das Geile, Tanzen erlaubt es, Tanzen ist ja eine körperliche Flexibilität.
Das Tanzen erlaubt dir ja eine körperliche Flexibilität. Das Tanzen erlaubt dir ja auch, körperlich flexibel zu sein. Das heißt, in einem normalen Gespräch, wenn irgendwie auf einem Empfang oder so jemand mit dir redet, mit dem du nicht reden willst, dann hast du ein riesiges Problem. Man steht sich gegenüber und man braucht einfach einen sehr, sehr guten Grund. Hallo, Abstand. Hallo, Abstand. Man braucht einfach einen sehr guten Grund, um zu gehen. Wohingegen in der Disco ist man eh in Bewegung. Man kann sich einfach zwei Schritte nach links, fünf Schritte nach rechts, acht Schritte nach rechts und man ist schon wieder auf dem Ganzen. Man ist auch nachweisend. Man ist auch nachweisend. Das ist mir egal. Man tanzt sich wieder raus auf die Straße am Türsteher vorbei. Und man ist eigentlich flexibel. Deswegen glaube ich, das ist vielleicht auch so einer der Vorteile. Das ist eine ungezwungene Kommunikation. Ich habe mal einen Tanzkurs gemacht, das ist, glaube ich, eineinhalb Jahre oder so her. Da habe ich mit einer Tanzpartnerin einen Tanzkurs gemacht und wir haben auch irgendwie so ein, keine Ahnung, Abzeichen oder so, weiß ich gar nicht. Seepferdchen, ja. Seepferdchen im Tanzen. Es ist ganz schön krass, also es ist auch total lustig. Ich habe das auch als so eine riesen Comedy-Veranstaltung wahrgenommen. Weil du kannst dann da, also du musst halt die Frau führen und die vertraut halt auf dich. Und dann sind halt so, es war ein kleiner Raum, es war ein kleiner Kurs mit acht Paaren oder so, und dann ist man da rumgeeiert, und ist immer so, als Mann muss man halt immer so, wie beim Autoscooter, durchmanövrieren. Genau, ausweichen. Und es ist immer sehr lustig, wenn man die Frau irgendwie gegen ein anderes Paar tanzt, wo man so ein anderes Paar gefunden hat, die auch das locker sehen, und dann einfach zusammen so Autoscooter mit anderen Paaren abdrängt.drängt und Paare drängen, einfalls in die Blumen gefallen.
Aber natürlich hat man es auch absichtlich gemacht, natürlich hat man andere gerammt und vor allem immer so die Strebertänzer, die dann immer so mit ganz erhobenem Kopf und hohem Kinn durch die Gegend gehen und du einfach immer in den Reihen einfach. Entschuldigung, tu mir das Handtümer. Ja, ja, genau. Aber auch damals, es gibt dann immer so Kreisbewegungen, Walzer zum Beispiel.
Ja, Walzer ist ultra hart. Wo man dann auch immer schon, schon wenn man sich so nach links tanzt gegen die Wand, man schon absehen kann, ich kriege die Kurve nicht mehr vor die Wand, weil die Schritte erlauben ist nicht und man einfach sehenden Auges ins Messer gegen die Wand läuft. Weil dieser Dreivierteltag, der fuckt dich total ab. Ja, der macht dich wahnsinnig. Du musst halt immer, du musst halt innerhalb mit zwei Schritten musst du dich und die Frau einmal komplett 360 Grad drehen.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist ganz schön abgefahren.
Und das musst du halt auch so teilen, dass du halt insgesamt kleine Runden drehst, aber in einem Kreis, in einem grossen Kreis. Ja, genau. Das heißt, du musst außen hin schneller werden. Das heißt, du musst auch wahnsinnig weit vorausplanen. Du musst den Raum schon erkannt haben. Genau. Und alle anderen Paare ja auch, die ja auch eher Bewegungen machen und auch nicht klarkommen. Das ist extrem stressig. Und als Anfänger, und das sind ja alles Anfänger, hast einfach keine Chance. Und das ist total krass. Und die wird auch wahnsinnig schwindelig. Die wird wahnsinnig schwindelig. Deswegen, es gibt ja diesen Move, wo man, sag ich mal, aus der Umarmung sich löst und die Frau so ein bisschen wegschickt. Den habe ich alle fünf Sekunden gemacht, einfach nur, um mich zu orientieren im Raum. Einfach um ganz kurz zu gucken, wo bin ich gerade, wo ist die Fensterfront. Okay, gut, weiter geht's. Und dann immer wieder, wo bin ich jetzt nochmal, weil man sieht ja auch relativ schlecht, weil meine Partnerin hatte immer wallendes Haar um mich herum und dann habe ich sie einmal gedreht und ich hatte ihr Haar um meinen Kopf gewickelt. Zwei Meter langes Haar. Ich hatte ihr um meinen Kopf gewickelt, was einfach der Situation auch nicht geholfen hat, was sie glaube ich auch gemacht hat, um mich zu verarschen. Was ich bis heute nicht verstehe, manchmal wechseln die Partnerinnen ja auch und mir sind zwei Partner Partnerinnen hingefallen. Mir sind zwei Partnerinnen hingefallen. Und was verstehst du daran jetzt nicht? Ich verstehe nicht, wie das passieren konnte. Es ist noch nie, der Tanzlehrer meinte, das wäre ihnen noch nie passiert. Es wäre schon mal passiert, dass jemand gestolpert ist oder so. Aber es sind zwei Mädchen, die sind wegen mir, beim Tanzen, mit mir umgefallen. Ich war die Riesenlachnormale in diesem Tanzkurs. Ja, kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass du mit deinen zwei Meter achtzehn mit irgendwie Anita, die eins sechzig ist, dass du da irgendwie Probleme hast. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass du da ausserdem mal so ein Suplex nebenbei verführst. Aber auch da... Ich habe Kerzen gerade immer runtergucken müssen auf meine Tanzpartner. Kerzen gerade. Ja, genau. Was ja natürlich auch der Sinn der Sache ist eigentlich, ne. Ich habe jetzt war auch mein Problem mit der Repetition, dass man irgendwie so tanzt und man hat dann diesen Tanzschritt drin und man macht den dann fünfmal und man denkt sich, das Lied ist jetzt 20% vorbei, wir machen das jetzt einfach noch fünfmal, wir drehen uns einfach immer und immer wieder im Kreis, ich kann keine Figuren, ich kann nichts anderes, wir machen einfach immer dasselbe. Das hat mich einfach irritiert, aus diesem Modus nicht mehr rauskommen. Das wird ja immer cooler eigentlich. Hinten raus haben wir auch so ein paar Figuren gelernt, die dann wirklich ganz interessant waren. Und wir sind Zweiter geworden. Also ich bin sogar Zweiter geworden. Nee, Wettkampf kam es bei mir tatsächlich nie. Das war immer so ein Ding. Und ich wollte mich auch nicht binden. Oder es gab einen, die anderen haben auch gesagt, okay, du bist ausser Konkurrenz. Oder ich habe es nicht gemerkt. Ja genau, warum muss ich heute früher gehen? Ich wollte mich tatsächlich auch nie an diesen Tanzkurs binden, es kamen dann alle Tanzkurs, die Tanzlehrerin auf mich zu und hat gesagt, du musst noch diesen Vertrag unterschreiben wegen Vereinsgebühren und so und du musst noch nicht so, ich habe leider keinen Stift dabei und ich muss noch mit meinem Finanzberater und jedes Mal über Monate hinweg habe ich nie diesen Tanzkurs abgeschrieben. Also schwarz getanzt. Ich war tatsächlich ab schwarz getanzt. Dann war du unf unfassbar gerne getanzt und war keines Geld nicht gern. Dirty Dancing, die berührendste Geschichte der Welt. Genau, ich konnte es mir nicht leisten, aber ich war so verliebt in Tanzen und in die Frau, dass ich es einfach nicht anders konnte. Sonntag ist Muttertag, wollte ich noch mal kurz sagen. Das ist so der Nachteil, wenn man die falschen Sendungsnotizen benutzt. Ja, ich habe noch nicht außerdem die letzten. Ach Gott. Wie wollen wir denn eine Rubrik machen? Oh, herzlich willkommen zur neuen Rubrik. Wuh, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, wau, w in einem Flugzeug Tomatensaft bestellt hat?
Ich glaube nämlich, es war so, ja, hey, ich kriege einen Tomatensaft und plötzlich der ganze Flieger steht langsam auf.
Ja, das passt perfekt zusammen.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Kapitän ignoriert einfach, er hört einen Tomatensaft, what, best Idee ever. Perfektes Verhältnis. Und wir hatten ja letztes Mal der erste Mensch, der geritten ist. Und heute, alles okay. Ich sehe, vor mir ist ein Fernseher, hinter dir ist ein Fernseher. Und da kann ich das hinter mir sehen. Und da ist ohne Scheiß irgendwas vorbeigegangen. Das kann nicht sein, da ist nur eine Tonkabine, da ist ein abgeschlossener Raum. Hallo? Sau gruselig, ey. Ist gerade ein bisschen gruselig. Hallo? William? Bist du es? Ja. Hallo, Florentin. Ich muss dir mal was erzählen. Also, nie sagen jemanden anders. Nie sagen jemanden mehr anders als du jetzt. Also, William. Okay. Wir haben das letzte Mal gesprochen über die erste Person, die jemals geritten ist auf einem Pferd. Und heute die erste Person, die jemals auf einem Pferd saß und höher gesagt hat. Und ich stelle mir nur so vor, das Pferd so reißt die Augen auf. Fuck, sie haben das Wort. Fuck it. Und reitet los, wie will sie wissen. Ja genau, sie haben unseren Schwachpunkt. Und bis dahien immer so, auf geht's, Kollege. Komm, jetzt aber, los.
Und irgendwann eines Tages
Hüa und
Wusch war das Pferd weg.
Und ab dann hatten sie den Schlüssel, um diese Rasse
zu knächten. Krass, ey. Muss ja auch immer mal
gemacht haben. Pferde-Rennen gewinnen ja auch die Jockeys, die am
schönsten Hüa sagen. Ja, genau. Hüa!
Hüa! Hüa!
Hüa! Ne, ich glaube, es war eher ein Schlachtruf.
Hüa! Weiß ich nicht. So ein Husten. Nein, ich glaube, es war eher so was sein für so Hüa. Hüah! Hüah! Nee, ich glaube, es war eher ein Schlachtruf. Hüah! Weiss ich nicht.
Ich glaube, es war eher so was sein für so Hüah.
Hüah. Hüah.
Färd weg. Ja.
Ich habe, ähm,
ich weiss nicht, bist du katholisch? Ja.
Hei gut, ich auch. Lass uns vor kurz
alle Evangeliten,
Protestanten ausschliessen,
indem wir darüber sprechen,
ich weiß nicht, ob es auch so ist, ich glaube auch,
der erste Mensch, der in der Kirche den Pfarrer geantwortet hat.
Ich war noch nicht auf einer Kommunion,
und ich fand es echt, wenn man das wirklich objektiv betrachtet,
ist das wirklich lustig, wenn er sagt,
im Vater, der Sohn und dem Heiligen Geiste,
Amen, und die ganze Gemeinde,
Amen, oder erhebe die Herzen,
wir haben sie beim Herrn,
die ganze Gemeinde redet plötzlich, was wirklich aussieht wie so eine totale Sekte. Und ich habe mich gefragt, wer war der erste Mensch, der plötzlich dem Pfarrer geantwortet hat? Wahrscheinlich hat sich niemand getraut, das in Frage zu stellen, und so ist es einfach entstanden. Irgendwie so der Pfarrer war da einfach dagegen. Erhebe die Herzen, ja, wir haben sie beim Herrn. Was? Er gibt auch keinen Sinn. Wir haben sie beim Herrn, hey. Ja. Woher kommt das? Also ich habe alle gleichzeitig antworten.
Gute Frage. Ich glaube, ich hatte einfach mal
irgendjemand, der es nicht verstanden hat, war einfach dabei und hat einfach
mitgeredet, einfach so Gespräch gewürzt.
Ja, mir geht's auch gut.
Der erste Mensch,
der geschwitzt hat,
was ist dem durch den Kopf gegangen?
Vielleicht ich regne?
So, nächster. Die Rubrik nimmt auch, das wird auch immer schwieriger. Ich möchte auch ganz kurz einen Zuschauer herausheben, und zwar Pierre Felsenheimer, der seinen eigenen Vorschlag gebracht hat, und zwar der erste Mensch, der geschwommen ist. Tatsächlich auch ein schöner Moment. Ich finde, der erste Mensch, der wirklich in der Schwimmtechnik auch geschwommen ist.
Ja, glaube ich auch. Der erste Mensch, der wirklich in der Schwimmtechnik
auch geschwommen ist. Ja, auch geil.
Aber dass man auch gemerkt hat,
dass man gemerkt hat, wir können uns
im Wasser fortbewegen.
Es gibt so ein sehr gutes Interview mit Bushido.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Bushido ist.
Sagen wir es einfach mal, ein bekannter deutscher Rapper.
Du kennst doch einen.
Ja, genau. Ich kenne nur Echo Fresh.
Und der ist ja, der ist anscheinend Evolutionsgegner und er glaubt nicht so ganz an die Evolutionstheorie. Und dann wurde er interviewt zu dem Thema und dann ist er so ein bisschen der Knackpunkt der Evolutionstheorie, dass sich viele Leute nicht vorstellen können, dass eines Tages einfach ein Organismus, der im Wasser lebt, einfach an Land gegangen ist und so lange überleben konnte, dass er sich vorpflanzen konnte und diese Fähigkeit weitergeben konnte, weil er war nicht dafür gemacht, an Land zu sein. Und so dieser erste Landgang stellt viele Skeptiker vor Probleme, wie man sich das vorstellen kann. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja das kann ja gar nicht sein, Fische gehen ja nicht einfach so an Land. Und dann hat der, der ihn interviewt hat, gesagt, naja, aber Menschen gehen ja auch ins Wasser. Und damit war er komplett still. Ja, stimmt. So, Thema beendet einfach. Es war nicht so eine schöne Antwort. Hat seinen Clan angerufen, der kümmert euch und macht den Typen. Er weist zu viel. Das muss auch ein geiler Moment sein. Der erste Fisch, der an Land geht, schleimig, stinkend, unter grossen, entsetzlichen Schmerzen, genauso wie das Podcast-Uf entstanden ist. Er war erstmal im sehr leichten Wasser. Seichten Wasser. Glaubst du? Ja. Wir sind auch gerade in so einem leichten so einem leichten, sehr schwebenden Wasser. Okay, auf geht's. Ich habe meinen Platz zwei, ich habe vier herausgesucht. Ja, bitte. Ja, ich bin ein Streber. Jedes Mal eins mehr. Die ersten Leute, die an Halloween-Süßigkeiten verlangt haben, bei abfremden Leuten. Ja, Süßes oder Saures. Nein. Nein, what? Warum sollte ich euch jetzt was Süßes geben? Ihr habt keinen Grund. Ja, oder auch. Oh, ihr habt euch was angezogen. Stimmt, oder auch in Geburtstagen oder so, einfach Geschenke einfordern. Ich habe heute Geburtstag. Stimmt, das ist ein Grund. Weil man plötzlich was verlangt. So what? Dass man so an einem Tag irgendwo hingeht, sich gruselig verkleidet, den Typen erschreckt und dann noch dafür was verlangt im Gegensatz. Oder die erste Person, die seinen Geburtstag bewusst gewusst hat. Weil die meisten Menschen wussten gar nicht, welcher Tag es ist im Jahr oder so und die Bauern irgendwie auf dem Land. Und einer hat mal gesagt, sag mal Leute, vor 18 Jahren wurde ich geboren. Oder, was mir gerade eingefallen ist, der erste Mensch, der erste Strassenkünstler, der einen Hut vor sich hingelegt hat. Ja, genau. Und die Leute wussten nie, was es bedeutet überhaupt. Und dachten, okay, jetzt zieht den Hut vor uns. Guter Typ, dem gebe ich Geld. Ja, gut Relativ einfach. Die erste Person, die an einer Tür geklopft hat. Und was haben sie dir da vorgemacht? Wenn man irgendwo rein wollte und so stand so, ich werde jetzt da. Hallo. Ich komme jetzt rein. Mein Name ist Geisermausel. Und man ist einfach gegen die Tür gelaufen. Geisermausel? Wie zur Hölle. Was geht denn deinem Kopf an? Man ist einfach so awkward vor der Tür gestanden und hat einfach gewartet, bis die Person zufällig aufmacht. So, wow, okay, hallo. Das ist genau wie ich. Ich habe eine Sparkassenkarte und man braucht die Karte ja, um reinzukommen in die Sparkasse. Und meine geht nicht. Aus unerklärlichen Gründen komme ich in keine Sparkassenfiliale rein damit
und ich stehe da so richtig dumm vor der Tür und warte, bis
ein anderer kommt, der auch gerade Geld abhielt.
Oder auch die Situation, wenn man so durch so eine Lichtschrankentür
gegangen ist beim Aldi oder so und
eigentlich wieder raus möchte, aber nicht den ganzen Weg durch den
Supermarkt nehmen will und deswegen wieder rausgehen
durch diese Lichtschranken, man kann sie aber nicht öffnen
von der Tür und dann muss man aber warten, bis jemand anders
durchgeht und so, hallo, Montag, weil man meistens
halt auch so zwei, drei Ebenen durchgehen muss und immer wieder warten muss, wie bei Star Wars, Episode I. Naja, auf jeden Fall, weiter. Der erste Mensch, der geniesst hat. Was hat der gedacht? Was haben die Unmenschen gedacht? Okay, warum machst du das? Wie bitte? Lass es bitte. Was hast du gerade gesagt? Aber ich meine, es wäre doch auch mal cool, wenn es so etwas Neues gäbe.
Also wir können niesen, husten, sowas, das war's.
Aber wenn eines Tages einfach mal was Neues entsteht.
Ein Zwischending.
Ein Zwischending oder halt was ganz Neues, so dass man was ganz Neues macht,
irgendwie aus den Ohren niesen oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder irgend so etwas ganz anderes und dann einfach sowas.
Ab jetzt gibt es das halt so.
Die Menschheit hat sich weiterentwickelt und wir haben jetzt einfach nochmal eine weitere Sache. Das ist doch die Schwierigkeit in unserer Rubrik. Dinge entwickeln sich ja langsam, immer. Ja, das ist ja, daher kommt ja ein bisschen die Comedy-Rubrik, du Pfeife. Jetzt nehme ich das Mikro. So, ich habe jetzt noch der erste Flamingo. Hat sich wahrscheinlich auch gefragt, was zur Hölle soll ich denn sein? Das ist ein Witz. Herrgott, das ist ein Witz.
Ja, genau so. Wir haben Vögel,
ja, wir haben Vögel. Jetzt pass mal auf,
was ist Folgendes, wir stellen einen Vogel
auf Stelzen, okay,
und wir machen ihn pink.
Klar, warum nicht, du bist der Chef,
machen wir. Ich meine, irgendwann
wurde Gott doch auch langweilig. Wenn das Respektverhältnis
im Himmel zu willkürlich wurde.
Ja, genau.
Wir haben Würmer, oder? Ja, Würmerhammer, alles klar. Wie wär's mit Würmer mit Beinen? Ja, wir haben schon genug andere Tiere mit Beinen. Nee, nee, nee, Würmer mit Beinen und irgendwann werden sie zu Schmetterlingen und kriegen Flügel. Why not? Jupp, wir lassen sie da mal ganz kurz alleine, alles klar. Genau, wie wir uns eben kurz vor dem Podcast überlegt haben, der erste Mensch, der Mau Mau gesagt hat. Ja.
Wenn man spielt.
Mau Mau.
Bitte?
Entschuldige.
Was hast du gerade gesagt?
Mau Mau.
Ja, man kann doch Mau Mau sagen beim letzten.
Ja, okay.
Und da war das und so.
Einfach, die Geburtsstunde war ein.
Ja, okay.
Wenn man das realistisch angeht, es hat sich langsam entwickelt.
Erst hat er immer ein M gesagt.
M.
Und dann Ma. Mau. Ma. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. M. Ding haben sich langsam entwickelt. Oder ich habe auch mal hier. Der erste Mensch, der erbrochen hat. Der sich wirklich erbrochen hat. Ja, ich glaube, wir können alle Körperfunktionen so ein bisschen durchmachen.
Der erste Mensch, der jemand anderen erpresst hat.
Ja, oder die Metapher nicht verstanden hat.
Der erste Mensch, der Danke gesagt hat. Die erste Person, die sich gemeldet hat im Unterricht. Die erste Mensch, die Mamaau gesagt hat. Ich fange es mir auch nicht an. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart bei dieser Rubrik. Das war der erste Mensch.
Im Universum entstehen ja auch ständig neue Dinge. Das war der erste Mensch.
Im Universum entstehen ja auch ständig neue Dinge.
Die Sterne explodieren, schwarze Löcher, Wurmlocher schießen Materie durch die Galaxie.
Neue Dinge entstehen, Meteoriten, Asteroiden, was da so alles rumschwirrt in dem Universum, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Und wir Menschen kreuchen und fleuchen.
Fühlst du dich nicht auch manchmal sehr klein, dass du dir denkst, ich bin hier ganz alleine auf der Welt, niemand hilft mir, ich stehe ganz allein da, was ist da los? Ich denke vor allem, dass das Leben vergänglich ist. Es ist vergänglich, man… Es hört irgendwann auf. Das ist die Synonym von vergänglich. Aber… Irgendwann ist es vorbei, irgendein Abschnitt vorbei. Wird es nicht gerade dadurch, dass es aufhört, auch unendlich in seinen Möglichkeiten? Naja, es ist ja eine hochinteressante Vorstellung, in einer Welt zu leben, in der nichts ist, zum nichts zu werden, so Dunkelheit ins Schwarze zu wandern. Aber braucht es nicht auch das Nichts, damit etwas sein kann? Das setzt nicht Existenz, Nicht-Existenz voraus. Es bedingt es sogar, soweit würde ich dann doch gehen. Wäre nicht eine Welt, in der nichts existiert, wesentlich eher vorstellbar als eine Welt, in der überhaupt etwas existiert? Warum existiert überhaupt etwas? Gewohnt ist man nur, dass Dinge existieren. Eine Vorstellung daher einer Welt, in der nichts existiert, ist, wie ich finde, unmöglich. Und das macht den Reiz aus. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum sich Religionen entwickeln. Gibt es das nichts überhaupt im Grunde mehr als ein theoretisches Konzept, die Abwesenheit von etwas? Gibt es das auch tatsächlich oder ist es nur ein theoretisches Konzept, dass der Mensch sich durch den Vorgang der Subtraktion vorstellen kann? Es gibt ja nicht. Es gibt ja immer das Gegenteil. Es gibt Schwarz und Weiss, es gibt Hoch und Tiefe, es gibt immer das Gegenteil. Sehr interessant. Gehen Sie da bitte weiter auf ein. Und es gibt Materie und Antimaterie. Jetzt ist aber alles zum gleichen Masse vorhanden. Davon geht man aus. Aber Antim Ende der Gleichung... Hey, halt mal die Fresse kurz. Am Ende der Gleichung würde eine Null stehen normalerweise, entsteht aber nicht. Und das ist nämlich das Ding. Das Universum dürfte normalerweise gar nicht existieren, weil es genauso viel Antimaterie wie Materie gibt. Muss ja eigentlich so sein. Irgendwann ist aber Antimaterie verschwunden gegangen, deswegen gibt es mehr Materie und das ist was wir gerade haben. Es kann ja nichts aus dem Nichts entstehen. Also du meinst, das Universum ist nur eine falsch verteilte Balance. Es ist nur aus der Balance. Die Existenz ist eine nicht aufgehende Gleichheit. Es ist ein Fehler. Es ist ein Fehler im System. Also du willst sagen, Existenz ist ein Fehler. Existenz besteht nur daraus, dass zwei Pole nur wirklich weit aussehen. Und irgendwann macht mal jemand so einen Schrank auf, dann ist die fehlende Antimaterie da und wir sind alle weg. Ich glaube, irgendwann wird die gefunden und wir sind alle weg. Aber ist nicht so auch das Leben des Menschen aufgebaut? Existieren wir nicht auch als mehrere Pole, die unter sich Spannung erzeugen und mit Dingen ausserhalb von sich und sich selbst Spannung erzeugen? Die Konflikte sind ja hochinteressant. Ja, es ist ja unglaublich interessant. Also ist der Mensch selbst nicht einfach nur leer und lebt durch die Plus und Minus, die ihn erfüllen? Selbst an sich ist er allerdings nur eine leere Hülle? Ja, deswegen sind ausgeglichene Menschen, die Yoga oder Pilates machen. Verschwinden irgendwann einfach. Ja, die verschwinden irgendwann und sind auch ein bisschen langweilig. Ja, das ist ja die Idee eigentlich des Buddhismus mit der Erlösung und Nirvana, dass wenn du Balance erreicht hast, bist du weg.
Stimmt. Dann verschwindest du. Das heißt,
im Umkehrschluss... Das sind die Buddhisten auch wahnsinnige Arschländer.
Und wahnsinnig selten, auch einfach.
Ich bin hier raus, Leute.
Die arbeiten nur an der Exitstrategie.
Du kannst dich ja dann entscheiden.
Im buddhistischen Glauben ist es so,
wenn du die Chance hast, ins Nirvana zu gehen,
kannst du dich entweder entscheiden, ins Nirvana zu gehen
und bist dann weg, oder du bleibst auf der Welt und bist Lehrer und bringst anderen Leuten bei, wie man ins Nirvana geht. Und wirst, was war noch in der Redaktion mit dem Reinkarnation, wo du als anderes Tier wiedergeboren wirst? Hinduismus ist das. Ist das nicht, und was, also wenn man cool ist, hat man ein cooles Tier? Kastensystem. Ja genau, du hast Karma und je mehr Karma du hast, desto ein besseres Tier wirst du dann. Also wenn du mal jemanden umbringst, wirst du wahrscheinlich eine Eintagsfliege. Aber wo ich mir denke, auch so als, ich glaube, ich habe mich immer gefragt, welches Tier ist denn in der Hierarchie des niedersten Tieren? Ich glaube, es ist der Wurm, wo ich mir dachte, als Wurm saugeiles Leben. Weil du denkst, ich kann nicht weiter absteigen, es ist scheißegal, was ich mache, Wurm bin ich einfach auf jeden Fall, ist völlig egal. Ja, vor allem als Wurm denkst du auch nicht, das Leben ist scheiße. Du kennst es ja auch wieder nicht alle. Doch, du kennst es ja eben schon, weil du schon andere Leben gelebt hast. Also du kannst es ja auch. Naja, das wird ja immer die Religion im Stichwort entwerten, weil jeder weiss ja, dass er nichts vorher war. Vielleicht hat man schon so ein Gefühl. Also vielleicht strebst du dich zu irgendwas Höherem, weil du weisst, wie es ist. Ich finde, ich glaube, glauben eigentlich Priester zum Beispiel, also Religion ist auch eine gute Folge, aber vielleicht, schau das mal auf kurz. Ich finde, denken Priester manchmal, sind wir vielleicht verrückt, weil stellen sie die Religion nicht mal in Frage und sagen sich… Doch klar, das ist ja quintessentieller Teil von Religion, dass du die Religion in Frage stellst. Ja, aber dann stellen sie bestimmt Priester mega auf die Frage, sind wir nicht verrückt Ja, klar. Das ist ja Theologie, dass du da einfach hinterfragst, was das eigentlich alles soll. Geht mal dann, liebe Leute, geht mal bitte zum Priester hin und sagt ihnen, ihr seid nicht verrückt, ihr seid nur wahnsinnig schön okay, passt schon, passt schon. Ist eigentlich Christentum die einzige Religion, wo die Leitperson ein Mensch ist, also genauso aussieht wie ein Mensch? Also ich meine, die Hinduisten haben ja diese Elefantenmonster und so. Ne? Das habt ihr jetzt nicht gesehen, da kann ich nur finstert reinschauen und müde mit dem Kopf schütteln. Natürlich nicht. Ich meine, das Judentum, das sieht quasi auf die gleichen Geschichten. Aber im Judentum sind auch die Bildnisse verboten komplett von Gott, oder? Es gibt aber Messias, auf den man gewartet, auf den gewartet wird. Und der ist halt immer noch ein Mensch. Dann zum Beispiel gibt es den Islam, da weiss ich nicht genau. Ja, okay. Ich habe jetzt nur den Hinduismus gedacht, tatsächlich. Der heilige Ali, weil es sich nicht wieder aussieht. Deswegen habe ich versucht, durch den Hinduismus abzugrenzen. Hinduismus ist mir einfach ein Dorn im Auge. Das ist einfach so ein Ding, da will ich nichts mit zu tun haben. Das ist echt so ein Erzfeind. Jeder braucht einen Erzfeind. Das Coolste ist eigentlich, was damals die alten Griechen geglaubt haben, an diese ganzen vielen Götter. Was voll geil ist. Da gab es einen Griech... Das ist sehr nah auch an dem, was heute zum Beispiel, wie die Republiken ja aufgebaut sind. Es gab quasi den Gott für Agrarwirtschaft, den Gott für Finanzen. Wie so ein Bundestag. Ja, also wie ein Bundestag aufgebaut. Total interessant. Das ist auch cool. Da kannst du halt immer an neue Götter beten und du kannst es ja ein bisschen besser zurechtbiegen, das ganze so. Ja, und die Götter sind vor allem auch viel menschlicher. Ich kann sagen auch, ich scheide es noch nicht. Nur dadurch menschlich machen, dass es mehrere gibt. Wenn es einen Gott alleine gibt, ja gut, der ist halt allmächtig so. Aber schon wenn du zwei Götter hast, dann gibt es da Streit und einer ist stärker und einer ist stärker. Die Geschichten werden automatisch cooler. Die Bibel wird cooler einfach. Das ist eine mehrteilige Geschichte eigentlich. Ja, absolut. Wir sind durch mit der Zeit. Ich fand das eine gute Folge. Ich bin dankbar. Ja, danke schön. Nicht dir. Ja, danke. Vielen Dank, dass ihr wieder zugehört habt beim Podcast UFO. Ihr habt eine Menge Aufgaben. Ihr habt jetzt erstmal die Aufgabe, wenn wir nächsten Wochen auf der nächsten Party, auf die ihr geht, was wahrscheinlich morgen ist. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass unsere Hörer viel cooler sind als wir. Also wirklich, ganz im Ernst, ich kann nicht verstehen, warum ihr uns zuhört. Ich meine, ihr habt offensichtlich Sex, wie uns Leute auf Twitter schon unter die Nase reiben. Finde ich auch ein bisschen uncool also jetzt mal, also klar, natürlich, ihr könnt mal natürlich machen, was ihr wollt, aber dass man jetzt irgendwie sagt, so, oh, hier, keine Ahnung, ich könnte entweder euch hören oder Sex haben, mal gucken, was ich mache, finde ich auch ein bisschen scheiße eigentlich, die Option hat nicht jeder, deswegen, haltet euch mal ein bisschen zurück, okay, Leute, auf jeden Fall, ihr habt jetzt die Möglichkeit, das trifft uns auch, das trifft uns auch, ja, wir haben auch Gefühle, könnt ihr auf der nächsten Party, auf die ihr nächstes Mal geht, Pauline, auf die nächste coole Sex-Organ-Party, auf die du wieder gehst, kannst du mal versuchen, irgendjemanden einen Sitzplatz zu klauen und erzähl uns, wie es gelaufen ist, ob es funktioniert hat, ob du genug Selbstbewusstsein hattest, ob der Auftritt cool genug war. Ihr könnt uns weiteren Sprachnachrichten hinterlassen auf unserem Skype-Account. Ja, könnt ihr mir auch nicht. Das Podcast-Ufo. Könnt ihr mir auch nicht, weil Flurken ist verkackt. Nee, ich hab das jetzt alles eingerichtet und ich will, dass es auch funktioniert. Das ist auch satt. Nee, das passt doch. Ich hab's auch satt, dass du immer Dinge versprichst. Aber ich hab's eingehalten, die Leute halten sich ein. Man muss uns eine Kontaktanfrage schicken. Ja und, kann man doch machen. Ja okay, mach. Ja und, schickt uns eine Kontaktanfrage, ich nehme alles an. Und ansonsten könnt ihr uns natürlich auch wieder... Das geht auch privat für Florian. Könnt ihr uns natürlich auch alles an. Uns Bilder schicken und neue Themenvorschläge schicken, wenn ihr wollt, ansonsten orientieren wir uns das nächste Mal wieder an Cowbuttler, wenn ihr irgendwelche Scheißthemen wollt, wir machen, wir ziehen das durch, ist mir völlig egal, bis wir, solange bis wir von Booster und Cowbuttler gesponsert werden, bis zum nächsten Mal, haut rein, viel Spaß dabei und denkt immer daran, das Universum ist unendlich und ihr seid es auch. Ergreift jede Möglichkeit, lasst euch nicht sagen, dass ihr irgendwas
nicht könnt, wenn ihr nur genug daran glaubt,
könnt ihr alles schaffen. Tschüss, macht's gut.
So soll das nochmal einen großen Redeanteil haben.
Macht's gut. Tschüss.
Wir sind abheben, ab.